>> Bret: WE WILL TALK TO THE
AGRICULTURE SECRETARY IN JUST A
MINUTE, THE SENATE HAS JUST
APPROVED A $19 BILLION DISASTER
AID PACKAGE THAT NOW GOES TO THE
HOUSE.
IT HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED IN SIZE
SINCE THE HOUSE FIRST ADDRESSED
THIS LAST YEAR.
IT WOULD ALLOCATE ALMOST A
BILLION AND A HALF DOLLARS TO
PUERTO RICO, THE MOST SINCE IT
WAS DEVASTATED BY HURRICANES
IRMA AND MARIA IN 2017.
ALSO MONEY FOR U.S. SOUTHERN
STATES, MIDWESTERN STATES
DELUGED WITH SPRINGTIME FLOODS
AND A FIRE RAVAGED RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE FOUR AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS REQUESTED
BY THE PRESIDENT TO HANDLE
MIGRANTS OF THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
HE SAID HE WILL GET THAT
IMMIGRATION MONEY LATER.
SEVERE WEATHER HAS TERRORIZED
PARTS OF THE MIDWEST AND THE
PLANES THIS WEEK AND IT MAY NOT
BE OVER.
MORE TODAY OF WHAT WAS DESCRIBED
AS A VIOLENT TORNADO RIPPED
THROUGH MISSOURI'S CAPITAL CITY
AND FLOODING REMAINS A MAJOR
PROBLEM IN OKLAHOMA.
CORRESPONDENT MATT FINN IS IN
JEFFERSON CITY, MISSOURI,
TONIGHT.
>> THREE PEOPLE ARE DEAD IN
MISSOURI AND HUNDREDS ARE
RETURNING TO DAMAGED HOUSES AND
BUSINESSES AFTER POWERFUL
TORNADOES RIPPED THROUGH THE
REGION IN ONE OF THE HARDEST HIT
AREAS OF JEFFERSON CITY, ONE
YOUNG MAN SAID HE AND HIS MOTHER
CURLED UP TOGETHER AND PREPARED
FOR THE WORST.
>> THE HOUSE STARTED SHAKING AND
ALL THAT, ALWAYS SAID IS I LOVE
YOU, YOU CAN'T SAY I LOVE YOU
ENOUGH UNTIL YOU ARE GONE.
>> A MOTHER SAID SHE FOUGHT
TEARS WITH HER DAUGHTER AND RAN
WITH HER INTO THE BATHROOM.
>> NOTHING MATTERS, I DON'T
CARE, I'M JUST HAPPY WE ARE
OKAY.
>> MISSOURI GOVERNOR MIKE PARSON
ASKING FOR THE NATION'S PRAYERS
FOR THE AT LEAST THREE DATA NEAR
GOLDEN CITY MISSOURI WHILE
SAYING HE'S GRATEFUL THERE WERE
NO DEATHS FROM THE DEVASTATING
TORNADO THAT RIPPED THROUGH
PARTS OF THE CAPITAL CITY.
>> WE DID EVERYTHING WE COULD TO
WARN PEOPLE, TO GET TO SAFETY
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DID.
>> MANY STATES ARE NOT IN THE
CLEAR.
THE FORECAST CALLS FOR MORE
POTENTIAL TORNADO OUTBREAKS FROM
TEXAS TO MECCA NEW YORK.
THE MISSOURI RIVER IS EXPECTED
TO CREST AT 9 FEET ABOVE STATE
LEVEL AND THE FLOOD OF
MISSISSIPPI RIVER WILL BE CLOSED
TO COMMERCE AND RECREATION NEAR
ST. LOUIS.
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW, NOT EVERY
NEIGHBORHOOD LIKE THIS ONE HAS
BEEN CLEARED, SEARCH AND RESCUE